[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час для уроків англійської,
мене звуть Едвін комітет, і я
запрошую вас продовжити нашу подорож,
прочитати фразу та передбачити слова в
пропусках.
для літа
все життя заради щастя я подорожую, що
ви думаєте про цю ідею цього ключа до
щастя, чи б ви хотіли провести життя,
відкриваючи нові місця, які можуть бути
переваги та недоліки такого
способу життя, давайте подумаємо про один аргумент
за та проти використання фраз  з
одного боку, з іншого боку, подивіться на
цих людей,
які вони відомі українські тревел-
блогери, журналісти Антон Тоскан Метро
Камаров і лісовий зоопарк чи дивилися ви
їхні відео, які частини
світу вони вже відкрили, а сьогодні
ми будемо читати і  скористайтеся паперовою
статтею про для авторів подорожей,
ви потренуєте свої навички читання, дізнаєтесь
, як використовувати одну стратегію для екзаменаційних
завдань і переглянути граматику, але перш ніж ми
підключимо
подивіться на ці слова чи знаєте ви
їхнє значення
давайте разом перевіримо, чи з’явилося
це несподівано чи випадково
з’явилося,
ви не очікували, що це з’явиться,
коли я можу з’явитися на дорозі праворуч,
повторіть дієслово to turn  вгору ще раз,
щоб підняти його другий -
піти піти втекти покинути
місце або людина тик тик
піти геть геть геть час від часу
я хочу піти від усього
цього  Фактично шоу to get
away from it all to get away повторити
дієслово get away get away
the first one was to turn up the second
to get away get the next to dismiss
у контексті, який вам доведеться відмовитися від
страху, щоб ігнорувати  to dismiss
повторити дієслово dismiss okay як
ти звільнив страх dismiss okay
наступний відкладати когось відкладати
відлякувати ти не роби це,
щоб відкладати когось не намагайся відволікати мене зараз
ховається за цим don'  Я ще не намагався мене
відволікти, тому першим було
підняти другу, щоб піти  отримати наступний, щоб
відкинути страх номер чотири полягав у тому, щоб
вимкнути когось
отримати наступний, щоб бути зламаним, щоб не мати
грошей, щоб закінчилися гроші, щоб бути зламаним,
повторити це слово зламався,
щоб бути зламаним, не плутайте його з фразою бути
зламаним  broken це причастий час минулого від
to break broke це прикметник to be
broke to have no money it і
останній - це рахунок єдиний відомий тут
обліковий запис звіт або опис вашого
досвіду напишіть обліковий запис це давайте
перевіримо, наскільки добре ви"  я вивчив ці
слова готовий добре сказав ігнорувати страх
відмовитися від цього закінчитися гроші бути
зламаним добре втекти добре втекти приємно
статися несподівано стати хорошим таким
чином відбити бажання когось
відкинути і звіт або опис цього  це
обліковий запис, у якому сказано, що ми збираємося виконати завдання на
відповідність, тобто як це виглядає, що
ми повинні почати з читання текстів,
питань або самого завдання,
безумовно, щоб почати із завдання чому,
тому що це дає нам певний напрямок
контексту, що  тексти – це приблизно, тож у
нашому випадку йдеться про чотирьох людей, які
написали книги про подорожі, що ще ми
можемо дізнатися, що кількість
питань більше, ніж кількість
текстів, тож два дивних запитання,
що робити далі, давайте пройдемося по
стратегії  виконуючи завдання на встановлення відповідності, скажіть, що
перший прочитайте запитання та
знайдіть ключові слова, подумайте всі
синоніми цих ключових слів, які слова
ви можете знайти в текстах правильно, тому
першим почніть читати запитання та
покладіть ключові слова, що ще
я пропоную вам тут  мати у
своєму розумі образ для кожного питання,
легко уявити картину, потім
запам’ятайте багато слів, ми
разом зробимо те, що ви робите далі, щоб прочитати
перший текст і знайти ключові слова там,
а потім знайти відповідне запитання
і після цього повторюйте процедуру
знову і знову, але зверніть особливу
увагу на старі варіанти, подвійну
перевірку,
чи вони дійсно дивні, тож давайте втілимо
теорію на практиці, з чого ми повинні
почати з defi  безперервно читаючи
запитання, тож перше запитання полягає в тому, хто з
письменників упевнений у пошуку
рішень проблем, іншими словами, це
безпроблемна людина, а
саме та, яка може знайти рішення будь-якої
проблеми будь-якої проблеми, тому жодних проблем не буде,
якщо ця людина зможе знайти її рішення
означає, іншими словами, вони можуть придумати або
створити деякі рішення для вирішення
цих проблем, насправді ми думаємо
про синоніми отримати другий прийняти
рішення в IDI,
щоб хтось змішав і три плани
задовго до подорожі добре, тому перший
не проблема людина, другий  одна
будує плани заздалегідь отримати третя вибрала свій
спосіб транспорту через брак
коштів, тож давайте мати це зображення немає грошей,
я маю переїхати, тобто одна просто схопіть
когось і підіть направо, подивіться на це фото,
отримайте наступну, змушує її писати, щоб
відобразити події  коли вони відбуваються,
я думаю, що те, що я бачу, chubachi
беруть участь, поки я ага,
я бачу цей, і я пишу про це,
але хороший метод номер п'ять помітив
на  думки інших людей під час планування
однієї поїздки щось на кшталт вона запитала
багатьох інших людей, чи подумають вони про
це, а потім врахувала це під
час планування її подорожі та
останньої подорожі з наміром опублікувати
свій досвід, тому перед
поїздкою вона  знала напевно, що вона
напише книгу чи щось подібне, але
перегляньте ці шість запитань, чи можете ви
побачити ці шість зображень людей, просто
перевірте перше, без проблем, людину,
другу, заздалегідь плануючи й
попередньо плануючи третє, добре, ні  гроші
давайте шукати транспортні засоби
четвертий я думаю, що я бачу п'ятий
запитав усіх, а потім прийняв свої
рішення і останнім, яким вона ніколи не
ділилася з самого початку,
вона буде подорожувати і писати вставайте
час для читання, тому ми збираємося читати
кожен текст протягом двох хвилин ми
знаходили рядки, які збігаються з деякими
зображеннями, і вимикали його перед читанням,
записали літери від A до D і були
готові до читання  Щоб записати
цифри від 1 до 6 біля кожної літери,
установіть дві хвилини для кожного тексту
[Музика]
давайте перевіримо разом скажіть у тексті
подивіться фразу серед іншого більше
придумала власну тут туга за домом, ви
завжди можете щось імпровізувати  то, серед
іншого, це означає, що вона створила
або розробила інші рішення, чи звучить так,
ніби вона безпроблемна людина, я думаю,
так що
увійдіть у текст DI пішов мій верблюд,
тому що я був зламаний і не міг собі дозволити
та автомобіль, який ви бачите так брак  кошти,
і їй довелося знайти якийсь
транспорт, але в тексті вона пише
те, що бачила і відчувала, як це
виявилося на дорозі, виявилося власне
насправді це людина, я думаю, що я
бачу, Кейт і текст будь вона  письменниця, яка
досліджувала світ для того, щоб написати
зі своїм наміром зробити це
останнім кроком у вас  r стратегія зосереджена на
всіх питаннях, тож давайте зробимо це
разом,
непарні запитання — це число, щоб прийняти
рішення
заздалегідь.  до речі, це хороша фраза
фраза, а не рішення в житті прийняти рішення
підкиданням монети,
повторіть цю фразу, щоб вирішити,
підкинути монету, отримати і питання номер
п'ять, щоб помітити думку інших людей
у тексті B, ми читаємо, що  вона не
хотіла, щоб інші люди знеохочувалися,
вона намагалася не засмучуватися
, тому питання друге та питання
п'яте, як правило, виконано добре, зараз ми
зосередимося на тексті B і ми
знайдемо граматику, час для граматики
швидко подивіться  через текст і
з'ясуйте інфінітиви протягом 20 секунд,
скільки інфінітивів ви зможете
знайти
готовими, давайте перевіримо, що більше ніж
достатньо правильно,
які це функції, які
ми вивчали на наших попередніх уроках.
Ви пам’ятаєте нашу карту розуму,
щоб ми сьогодні знали, що інфінітиви
використовуються після деяких дієслів, прикметників,
запитальних слів.
знати, як розібратися, як розбиратися, питання, як
справитися добре, що ще happy to take
happy прикметник після прикметників happy
to take it і все більше і більше інших
інфінітивів пиво та їжа з 2 і
тут ми можемо знайти один інфінітив у
пасивному способі чи ви це точно бачите
не засмучуйтесь пасивний пасив be і дієприкметник минулого
напишіть його сьогодні, ми вивчимо ще
дві форми інфінітивів, які
виконують завдання, і ви дізнаєтеся, чи
хотіли б ви перевірити їх трохи пізніше
в кінці уроку, але спочатку давайте
вивчимо ці  дві форми нескінченності
і перша - безперервні інфінітиви,
ви не знаєте, що таке безперервні
інфінітиви, це, мабуть, жартує,
так як це приклад безперервного
інфінітиву, мабуть, жартує
c  ontinues right what's the formula of
continues дієслово to be і дієприкметник теперішнього часу,
коли використовувати його для вираження
тривалої дії після дієслів або
слів, які вимагають інфінітивів з нашої
карти розуму, тож ви, мабуть, жартуєте, а
не партнери чи Twitter чи інший
приклад I'm  я радий навчати вас
, це правда, я дуже радий
вчити вас, це надовго, я
просто вчитель кулінарії, звичайно, не
на короткий період часу я можу використовувати
поточний безперервний тут прямо я
навчаю вас  тижнів
після дієслова або прикметника рад я повинен
використовувати інфінітив, і тому замість
теперішнього безперервного я буду використовувати безперервний
інфінітив Я радий навчати вас,
подивіться на часову шкалу. Насправді ми
використовуємо те саме зображення для поточного
безперервного права  say one more time
present continuous використовується для вираження
безперервного процесу після дієслів або
слів, які повинні бути веселими.
Lieut my infinitives you turn to
practice think of your friends what they
must do going now t  привіт, мабуть, дивляться
уроки або вони, мабуть, грають у комп’ютерні
ігри, доповніть цю фразу,
мабуть, ваші друзі мають робити те, що добре, або ще один
приклад, який я зараз викладаю, але, можливо, я хотів
би займатися тим, що я хотів би
бавитися  золотий піщаний пляж
правильно доповніть цю фразу про вас Я хотів
би робити те, що отримати так що це
продовжує інфінітив
гарна робота та ще одна форма інфінітиву,
яка є ідеальною інфінітивом, давайте прочитаємо
ці два речення та відповідайте реченням
і цим джентльменам, хто з них може
скажи яку фразу я радий вчитися в
цій школі я радий, що
почав у цій школі, безперечно,
хлопець навчається, він ходить до школи, і
тому він радий навчатися в цій
школі, тоді як чоловік не може  йти до
школи правильно сказати, що він радий,
що навчався в минулому в цій школі.
d минулого дієприкметника давайте нагадаємо
про дію, що відбулася в
минулому після слів дієслів, які
вимагають інфінітиву, ми будемо використовувати досконалий
інфінітив, як у цьому реченні він
радий, що почав у тій школі,
подивіться, що
це  приклад він вибач, що він сказав
це він сказав це в минулому прямо
замість минулої дії ми будемо використовувати, щоб
мати ідеальний інфінітив він вибач
, що сказав це зараз перефразуйте наступні
два речення з ідеальним
давайте перевіримо разом вона рада, що
знайшла  таке гарне місце для життя у Гейт,
а друге він дуже пишався тим, що
допоміг своєму старшому брату добре попрацювати,
щоб перевірити діяльність, яку він робив раніше,
тому перше - це просто інфінітив, простий
інфінітив,
він, здається, багато подорожує, отримує в
другому  один, який ми бачимо зараз, він, здається,
зараз подорожує, а в третьому
насправді це результат, і ми використовуємо
ідеальний подарунок, ідеальний так, щоб результат
сказав, що він, здається, подорожував по
всьому світу
добре попрацював, виконавши цю вправу, яку він використав
продовжує інфінітив і ідеальний
інфінітив для домашнього завдання
на одному з попередніх уроків, які ви
дізналися, як писати твір за та проти,
чи пам’ятаєте ви урок з
Бергером, скористайтеся цими знаннями та
напишіть твір на тему  тема життя на дорозі
переваги та недоліки
дивитися завіса перемагає наш урок
закінчився дякую за участь, слідкуйте за
оновленнями та до скорої зустрічі
[Музика]
ви